There are a variety of very complex
things facing us,
you know,
and one of them is while the Iq issue
that we talked about,
another is this polarization between
left and right that seems to be
characterizing everywhere in the West.
You know,
what's the same in Australia,
New Zealand,
all through Europe,
in Canada,
in the US.
I think you guys are actually a little
more protected against the most places.
But um,
and then the other one is,
well we need to dialogue between Islam
and Christianity and Judaism for that
matter.
But I mean the big,
the big clash for the Western world is,
is Islam versus Christianity.
And you know,
people don't think about it in those
terms because many intellectuals in the
west think of themselves as secular,
but it's a massive,
it's a massive problem.
And I'm hoping to conduct a whole series
of conversations with,
with Muslims,
uh,
former and present pro and anti to try
to facilitate a dialogue because there's
lots to talk about.
I mean,
I've studied religious thinking a lot
and I'm pretty ignorant about Islam
because it's a complicated system and
it's difficult to get into.
But I can tell you that what I've read
about Islam has not made me feel better
about the chances of reconciliation
between the Christian and the Islamic
world.
So like I don't know what to make of the
fact,
for example,
I mean,
if you look at the figure of Christ,
and I don't care if you're religious or
not,
I don't even care if Christ existed or
dog,
and I certainly don't care at the moment
about claims to divinity or the lock
there up.
It's just speaking as,
let's say I'm speaking as a secular
intellectual as a figure.
He's a figure of peace.
I don't think that that's disputable.
I mean,
he certainly,
he wasn't a warlord.
That's,
that's one thing that's for certain,
he never led armies,
you know?
Whereas that's not the case with
[inaudible] at all.
Mohammad was clearly and indisputably a
warlord and so it isn't the obvious to
me what to make of that except that it's
bloody complicated in a child bride as
well,
I believe.
Yeah.
Well that that one is somewhat less
problematic to me because I think that
you can write that off to the cultural
morays of the time now.
Um,
I know that there's a weakness in that,
but I don't think we have to address
that.
But the,
when the founder of your religion spread
that religion by the sword,
it makes it rather difficult.
And when your religion has been
embroiled in a vicious civil war from
the day of Mohammed's death,
which is exactly the case in,
in Islam,
between the Sunni's and the,
and the Shiites,
that war started literally the day that
Mohammed died.
It's very difficult for me to see how
that can be reconciled with the claims
that Islam is a religion of peace.
Yeah.
We saw that one when Martin Luther
hammered some stuff on a door a long
time ago,
and the Protestants and the Catholics
just went their separate ways.
And I mean,
like there's been some rough feelings
over the years,
I suppose,
but no generational wars that I can
think of.
I mean,
right.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
there was plenty,
you know what,
as you said there was,
there's been plenty of Christian schism.
But the other thing too is that it's not
that easy to lay those at the feet of
Christ.
No.
Because,
because just even merely as an
architectural figure,
you know,
as,
as the western world's hypothesis of the
ideal man.
I mean,
as a moral character,
he was pretty much above reproach and I
don't,
well,
it's difficult for me to say the same
thing about Mohamad.
Now that might be because I'm an
ignorant old western white guy,
but like I'm doing my best man.
I'm a big hit by,
or a dow is in for example,
and there's great wisdom in Daoism and
I've found value,
real value in and so much of the
religious reading that I did,
I've done,
but I'm really stumbling with Islam.
It's really hard for me to,
to see it as other than a primarily
political system
and did,
and that's how it's being a imply
enforced right now with WWE.
That's what Isis is all about.
You know there were state establish a
religious caliphate,
you know,
across the borders of two two countries.
It's,
yes,
it's less about when I think of
religion,
yeah.
When I think of like the Christian
religion,
how it's applied here in my home state
of Georgia,
you know,
it's w w when when we go to church and
we tied,
that has very little to do with politics
at all.
There's,
there's that,
there's this huge massive separation
between religion,
politics for the most part in the u s
and could be,
there are moments of ambiguity and,
and tempers flare over and I'm a
monument on this piece of property or
no,
but that's as stiff as it gets.
Like,
like the scariest bit of that that I can
remember some drunk fellow ran over a
monument for the 10 commandments a few
months ago and tipped it over.
Like,
like,
like that's what happens when,
and a critical point,
like,
like if you're not a Christian Kyle and
you're,
you know,
Christian kind of alcove there and
Georgia,
no one ever is going to come to you and
say you have to pay a different rate of
taxes.
You have to go to different stores,
you have to the religious who are,
will not be enforced
as a law.
You know,
I'm not going to lose any hands.
I,
if I,
I can,
you know,
the Bible has many restrictions that it
places on Christians and I ignore all of
them virtual,
you know,
like I don't,
I know there's no,
like there's no,
yeah,
religious police to come and kick my
door in and drag me away and torture me
and threatened my family and,
and well,
it's also,
there's other,
there's other cataclysms that that are
on that exist on the conception in the
conceptual realm as well.
So,
you know,
the,
the states dominated by Islam are not
economically productive.
And that's quite an interesting mystery
and
they're not,
and many of the,
and many of the Islamic states that we
purport to regard as allies hold values
that are antithetical to our system.
And a Saudi Arabia is a classic example
of that.
And I cannot for the life of me
understand,
except in a psychoanalytic manner why
the radical feminists tolerate America's
Lli.
America's lie.
The fact that America is allied with the
Saudis,
it's just absent.
It's like,
it's like,
it's not much different as far as I'm
concerned,
that it would be if black people didn't
say anything.
If America was allied with a slave or a
black slave owning state,
which of course also happens in Saudi
Arabia by the way.
So when did the feminist,
it's gotta be because Muslims right now
are higher up on the victim hierarchy
than then.
So even if it's way over there,
they're not allowed to speak out against
sir,
I think it's their unconscious wish for
brutal male domination.
I know.
I'm,
no,
I like that.
That's fun.
I think it's the left's ability to
apologize for anything that's wrong.
I think that people on the left,
maybe I'm just as crazy as you guys are,
like the Muslims are oppressed women.
Oh,
that's cultural.
We need to understand that.
Oh guys think they're girls.
That's,
you know,
hey,
we need to understand where they're
coming from.
Everything.
They're so open minded to egg excuse
making,
even if it's horrific.
Yeah.
That's also the agreeableness say and we
were talking about earlier.
Yeah.
Because agreeable,
agreeable people agree.
You know,
that's,
that's why the term exists.
And yeah,
so there is a real uh,
Poland and if you ally that with high
openness,
which is that open mindedness,
you know,
that it's associated creativity,
you get agreeable openness.
Yeah.
That's definitely,
and he goes
wrong.
And I'll forgive you beating your wife
often if you're low in
conscientiousness,
everything you keeping really goes,
then bill more puts it nicely when he
says,
you know,
the left would not for one second be
okay with apartheid in South Africa.
Right.
They would just banging that drum hating
every second of the way.
But for some reason the oppression of
women in Saudi Arabia has gotten a
complete pass.
Yup.
And it's a real deal,
you know,
say it's real deal.
Yeah.
Heck,
just the driving thing alone.
Yeah.
Taylor,
can you hold that?
They liked her.
Yeah.
I broke up.
You broke it.
We couldn't hear what you were saying.
You're still a little frozen.
So,
um,
uh,
but yeah,
just taking away their ability to drive,
right.
Women don't have mobility without men.
That is hugely oppressive.
If you made that change in America and
none other than when you're walking
stuck at home than you actually don't
see
a more concrete embodiment of the idea
of individual autonomy than the
automobile.
You know,
I think maybe it was the Soviet Union's
import and then,
and then,
uh,
manufacturer.
If the automobile,
the doom communism,
because nothing screams autonomous
individual like a car,
right?
You drive it yourself.
You can go on any road.
No one tells you what to do.
It's like it's freedom.
And the fact that women can't drive in
Saudi Arabia,
it tells the entire story.
And so the fact I cannot understand for
the life of me why we are so blind in
the west,
that we make the assumption that those
people are our allies.
It's like in what
Jay
and things have switched around the lot.
I mean,
America is now an oil exporting country
again,
and you guys have been doing pretty good
on the fracking for natural gas front.
And you know,
the other thing that's quite a bit worth
considering is that if the west wanted
to reduce its reliance on Middle Eastern
oil,
it can turn to Alberta and the tar
sands.
There's enough bloody oil there for,
for,
for the rest of humanity for the rest of
time.
You know,
and it's a bit messy,
but it isn't obvious to me that it's
better than,
it's worse than dumping $1 trillion
every five or six years into the coffers
of the Saudi princes.
Especially given there are obvious
responsibility for distributing the
most,
the most vicious Wahhabis propaganda all
over the world with the,
which is,
which is something that a fair chunk of
that petro money goes to.